we initiated a major literacy program
you know what I think keep teaching
people to read and write is a good thing
the truth is the truth and that's what
happened in the first years of the
Castro regime it's what he believes and
it's unacceptable to our community it's
unacceptable to anyone in our country by
him to be President well that's for the
voters to decide but as far as I'm
concerned he's way off
well Democrats in South Florida don't
much like the literacy program of Fidel
Castro or that Bernie Sanders brings it
up but Bernie Sanders is the front
runner of this race and he will be under
attack on that debate stage seven
candidates as you look at them Joe Biden
Mike Bloomberg people who - JJ McCoy
which are Bernie Sanders Tom Steiner and
Elizabeth Warren now a lot of the
conventional wisdom and democratic
circles is that Bernie Sanders is a real
problem and that he might not win
against Donald Trump Peter Hamby with
the Vanity Fair a couple weeks ago wrote
a piece I was gonna read a little bit of
it everything about Sanders his ideas
his stubborn dogma is sometimes kooky
supporters his contempt for green room
culture and party circuit is completely
foreign to the intellectual and cultural
fabric of Washington in that universe
the claim that Sanders is unelectable is
more or less gospel some Trump advisers
are worried about Sanders strengths his
populist appeal perceived authenticity
his durable popularity with the same
white non-college voters who voted for
Trump Democrats fretting about the
prospect of nominating Sanders should
consider for a moment how the few years
in American politics have exposed the
frailty of conventional wisdom and
incremental thinking they may also might
also consider as an axe instead of
asking if Sanders is unelectable ask
another question what if Sanders is
actually the most electable Democrat in
the age of Trump hyper-partisanship
institutional distrust and social media
Sanders could be examined as a candidate
almost custom-built to go head-to-head
with Trump this year that was a few
weeks ago before Sanders went on the
roll what about all this let's bring in
our panel
Charles hurt opinion editor of The
Washington Times MOA Leith the executive
director of the Georgetown Institute of
Politics
and Jonah Goldberg editor-in-chief of
The Dispatch
whoa what do you think of that Pierre
hamby's onto something here look I I
think Bernie Sanders is going to have a
unique set of challenges should he be
the nominee
but I don't disagree with Peter that we
are in a different era one of the ways
Donald Trump won was by tapping in to a
sense of grievance amongst a whole lot
of people out there populist sense of
grievance and using that to turnout
voters that we haven't seen yet that's
the rationale of the Sanders campaign
that they can tap into a populist sense
of grievance and turnout and a whole new
group of people the first three states
we haven't seen him do that he hasn't
expanded the electorate in the first
three states and I think comments like
that one on the literacy program in Cuba
might be a challenge in some places but
then again you know what the heck do any
of us know we were we were all saying
there's no way Donald Trump can win four
years ago and he proved us wrong don't
count him out Joe Biden is in a position
in South Carolina where he really needs
a win has to have one he's got an ad
against Bernie that's airing in South
Carolina now Bernie Sanders told fellow
senators he'd take on Obama when it
comes to building on President Obama's
legacy Bernie Sanders just can't be
trusted the question is how Joe Biden
can be trusted on the debate stage and
his previous performance and what
tonight could bring I mean it clearly
it's gonna bring fireworks ya know it's
gonna empty out the storehouse of ammo
on everybody I think but the basic
problem Biden is he increasingly sounds
like one of those bad lip-reading videos
you see on the internet where words that
do not go correctly in the order in
which he is saying them come out of his
mouth with the alarming frequency I mean
today with the US Senate running for the
US Senate
look I mean he's talking about getting
arrested visiting Nelson Mandela that I
mean it's like where is the nurse to
rein him in and that's his real problem
if he could come out and reassure people
with more than shouting and anger that
he was fully in control of himself I
think he'd be in a much better position
but there's a nervous making aspect
to his candidacy at this point like
maybe he just can't go the distance and
I think Democratic voters are picking up
on that all right here is Bernie Sanders
from 60 minutes and representative
Clyburn what democratic socialism is
about you're saying let's use the
federal government to protect the
interest of working families yeah nobody
who refers to himself as a Democratic
Socialist that word has always had
really dire consequences throughout
South Carolina
you know usually endorsements don't mean
a lot representative Clyburn endorsement
means a lot actually and so yes and if
he does pull the trigger for for Biden
and gets behind him
maybe that moves him across the finish
line yeah and also the the sort of non
endorsements like the one from Donna
shillelagh you know what people are
saying and Mike Bloomberg what people
are saying about Bernie Sanders right
now and I know that you know people come
together once the nominee is picked but
I have a hard time imagining how these
people come back around and support
Bernie Sanders after some of the things
that they've said raises another big
question for me well you know where is
Barack Obama his he risks having his
entire legacy you may not agree with it
but he risks having his entire legacy
being destroyed by this guy whether he
wins or he loses and he's sitting on the
sidelines I don't get it but but you
know the similarities between Trump and
Sanders is that they're both they both
reveal the dissatisfaction of regular
voters with their party's huge
anti-establishment fervor and and I
think it's real and I think even that
that's the the populist left and the
populist right the traditional
establishment has faded into oblivion